if China basically has the predominant
influence in the area Congressman
Michael Walsh represents Florida former
Greenbrier Congressman how important was
that military operation last night to
get our people out of the embassy
well Brian I want to give you know my my
fellow special operators and the people
the intelligence community and and
others behind the scenes uh real kudos
for for pulling off a great operation I
mean just take a step back though why
does why does Sudan matter uh so much
well number one it's the third largest
country in Africa it has huge amounts of
Natural Resources including gold which
is one of the reasons Russia is so
interested uh and and and thirdly it has
a port on the Red Sea that 10 percent of
uh of of the global Shipping of global
trade passes by as it gets to the Suez
Canal so uh this is this is an important
country in in geopolitics the Russians
are there in a big way because they want
the gold and natural resources and
China's there in a big way because they
want the same and they want to control
access to the Suez Canal that 10 of
global trade passes through Congressman
we have this is our fourth Embassy we've
abandoned and I'm glad everybody's safe
and they got to make the decision and
now we're on the ground trying to get
our six some of our 16 000 Americans on
the ground out and these operations
aren't going in the middle of a civil
war it seems where over 400 are dead and
and I think most of the hospitals have
been shut down this is important but
there's no proof that China left their
Embassy or Russia left theirs in fact
there's a presence of the Wagner group
there that mercenary force on the ground
so this is the same Sudan that was part
of the Abraham Accords wasn't it during
the previous administration brought into
the family of Middle Eastern Nations
recognizing Israel
yeah you've got China in there you know
as as the as the superpower as the
mediator but just two years ago Brian
Sudan was part of the Abraham Accords it
was cutting deals with Israel it was
part of President Trump's Middle East
peace plan something that nobody said
could be done something that any other
president would have received a Nobel
Peace Prize for and now it's become
completely unraveled the United States
is is abandoning the scene and once
again like in so many other places you
have China right and Russia filling the
void and oh by the way we pulled all of
our government people out with Americans
left behind and I'm hearing from the
same groups again the same groups that
had to go rescue Americans in
Afghanistan groups like Dynamo Allied
airlift and others are now being asked
by the state department to go in on
their own dime
to go help Americans uh get out I mean
it's just par for the course for this
administration's foreign policy that has
the world on fire you mean The Men Who
cash in their 401ks to help out people
in Afghanistan I've been asked to go
help Americans out in Sudan for free
don't we have a government for that in
operations uh incredible uh Brian it's
uh go ahead real quick I asked one of
them I asked one of them are you getting
any money from the state department for
this they said no we're going on our own
dime but you know what Americans are
left behind and we never ever leave
Americans behind we're gonna go even
though it's on their own money because
they're just great Americans right uh
and by the way just a great generation
of War Fighters and it looks like Russia
is trying to dominate with the Wagner
group Africa we need a plan to counter
it uh the USS truxton is in the area
Destroyer to hopefully hold on to that
Port thanks so much Congressman for all
you do
all right thanks Brian all right hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else